hey everybody it's Mike frieder back
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm here with the compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control
sc.l2-3.13.14 control monitor the use of
voice over IP Internet Protocol
Technologies
because everybody needs a little
eavesdropping
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all the cmmc
dvars and this SP Hunter 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so this is a challenging control to
understand almost because it is too
intuitive it's not a trick question as
many people in the past had assumed what
they're ultimately looking for is to
understand how your voice over IP system
works and how you control a monitor who
is using it and what's being done with
it so understand how to solve this
better let's dive into the assessment
points which I think will make it much
easier to explain by the way if you
don't have any Voiceover IP technology
in place well you might want to think
twice because things like zoom and teams
and WebEx those are all Voiceover IP
Technologies so uh you probably use them
somewhere in your business it might just
be a physical it might just not be a
physical telephone so what are they
looking for one determine if use of
voice over IP protocol Technologies is
controlled
what does a sample answer look like well
we might say the organization utilizes
voice over IP phones uh you know just
because it's easier to give an example
when you do use them which utilize
encryption and is set to require
passwords on voicemail boxes the phone
system is controlled by the voice uh
voice over IP system administrator VoIP
phone system access is only possible
within the physical premise right that's
pretty normal and no cui is stored on
voicemail per company policy so again
there's a policy in there too but again
also only authorized devices are allowed
to connect to the phone system right so
things that have been activated and Mac
address onboarded and things like that
now second control Point determine if
use of voice over IP Technologies is
monitored Voiceover IP system is
monitored by the IT team via automated
system alerts which are sent via email
and based on issue severity added to the
it ticketing system for review and
problem resolution that's one possible
answer we could also say hey look
um you know Voiceover IP system is going
to email alerts directly to somebody
yeah maybe the 84 the VoIP phone system
administrator lots of different ways to
monitor that stuff again it's all about
how your system is set up so that answer
should be customized into uh you know
your own company and hey if you need
help doing that the good news is that on
on call we work with defense contractors
just like you to do exactly that
especially when they've had this dfars
nist itar and cmmc compliance stuff
dropped into their laps like a seagull
on a sunny day we teach you how to level
up and be a proper on-call compliance
hero for your company eliminating gaps
great areas and getting this solved all
while showing you how to leverage
compliance is your secret weapon to land
more Defense work with higher profit
margins now that's what becoming an
on-call compliance hero can do for you
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
complianceecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash that subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance runs
roll it out until next compliance my
friends stay safe and secure out there
and hit us in the comments below to let
us know what you'd like to know more
about when it comes to information
security and compliance I'll see you on
the next one
[Music]
foreign